uh so much to talk about first of all i
know that andy gave you a nice embrace
there you guys go way back
we do we did i did my first movie ever
with andy
which movie was that pootie tang oh you
did you were
hey hooty tang
i have i've said this for many years
greatest name of a film ever
is pootie do you know the full name of
the film which is the full name of the
film
no i don't actually get it together
sorry
tang in sign your pity on the runny kind
which was great when i told my parents i
got my first acting job and i said i'm
going to be in a movie
it's called pooty tang in sign your pity
on the runny kind
and they were like what
but they're happy now what was your you
guys you played and played my daughter i
played a daughter
i played um yeah uh uh i think i was in
like a catholic school uniform
yeah and you were a radio executive i
was you know a wreck a record producer
uh with a big cigar just remember cigar
and a hat
oh yeah and you being driven wild with
desire by pooty tank
in a catholic school outfit yeah yeah
what was the whole thing
yeah you bet it was yeah but it didn't
make it into the movie
but they put it over the credits well
that's nice you could still be you can
still see it
now uh now you're doing this uh show
house of lies
and uh people really like this show i i
was what
i put in a a tape of the show tape a dvd
whatever you kids call it today not a
vhs
not a vhs uh i put in it was a disc of
some kind that went into a machine
okay and it showed you pictures and then
they gave me some applesauce and i went
to sleep
anywho the opening shot of the first
episode yeah is a tight shot of don
cheadle's naked ass
tight shot yeah and i i wasn't prepared
for that so i thought it was going to be
you
maybe in a you know cool outfit or
something and i'm right up next
you know uh i've always been prepared
for that to see that shot it's a
beautiful shot you guys
he's got these gorgeous cupcakes and he
just
he just drops trout all over the show he
shows them everywhere okay educate me
uh cupcakes is what cupcakes you know
well
oh okay well i better check for myself
uh
no but in his case chocolate cakes okay
do ladies and i'm just curious do ladies
refer to men's butts
as cupcakes or cakes i do
i don't know how common that is i i i i
have quite a few friends that well
there's different categories like if you
don't have cupcakes you might have
flapjack buns which is just
really flat this is dax's terminology by
the way
this is your your your man dax uh
he calls them what flapjacks flapjack
buns okay you know what i have
drywall i have just
i have i'm not kidding i have
carpenter's drywall
you just go low back to thigh i go there
is a straight line
from my low back to the back of my ankle
there is no disturbance there's no going
out
there might even be a little going in
it's not funny and you gotta do some
squats
i've done everything there's there's
nothing there and there's nothing to
build up many squats all the time you've
tried like
salting yes i've tried squats oh because
i looked like this i never did a squat i
love just saying you're a busy guy
you know give squats a little attention
i'm doing squats now as we talk
what i have no chair here i am
i'm holding myself perfectly still with
no ass
right now i i know and i didn't know i
didn't know that women prized a man's
butt i thought it was all about what's
up front
and then i find out
no you want to be what
whoops i'm just saying it's nice to have
a guy with a little bit of you know
nice cakes
what about you andy you're you've got i
don't know why don't you be the judge
[Applause]
the best place to go to commercial